painted a picture I thought I knew we
will I gotta have it
I've seen what isn't there Ariana Grande
is spilling the tea on her whirlwind
relationship with Pete Davidson and the
possible reason behind their split but
in my head singer stones on the cover of
Vogue magazines
August 2019 issue with her pup Toulouse
painting a very different picture from
last year when she and the Saturday
Night Live star were knee-deep in summer
loving the two got engaged in June 2018
after less than a month of dating but by
October they called it quits now fast
forward to Arianna telling vogue that
Pete was merely an amazing distraction
ouch
you see last year the singer moved from
Los Angeles to New York to have what her
friends were hoping would be a fun
summer do you do whatever you want
whatever you want whatever feels natural
be yourself
then she met Pete want to smoke some pot
or something
let's smoke some crack man now Arianna
tells the mag that a relationship with
Pete was frivolous and fun and insane
and highly unrealistic adding that I
loved him and I didn't know him it's
like flirty and young but it's sexy at
the same time she goes on to call
herself an infant when it comes to real
life adding quote I still don't trust
myself with the life stuff but before
there was Arianna and Pete is Mac the 26
year old singer was linked to the late
Mac Miller who died last September from
an accidental overdose grande tells the
mag her grief following his death was
pretty all-consuming she goes on to open
up about their two-year relationship
admitting that it was far from perfect
however calls Miller the best person
ever some tarts out there man just be
there for each other as much as we can
cuz you never you know when addressing
his struggle with substance abuse grande
explains that he didn't deserve the
demons he had she adds quote I was the
glue for such a long time and I found
myself becoming less and less sticky the
pieces just started to float away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]